lorsque le prince william a épousé kate
middleton des millions de
téléspectateurs du monde entier ont
observé l'héritier au trône britannique
choisir sa future reine
personne n'aurait alors cru que les
noces de son frère cadet provoquerait un
jour tout autant d'émoi et
d'anticipation
c'est sans doute parce que harry a
choisi de faire d'une jeune américaine
typique d'une authentique princesse
on dirait un conte de fées le prince et
l'actrice cette histoire a effectivement
tout l'air d'un film de disney c'est une
histoire de cendrillon tirée notre
enfance
histoire de meghan markle et du prince
harry a montré à de nombreuses jeunes
filles que ça peut aussi leur arrivée
elles peuvent devenir princesse tout le
monde me sentir princesse
nouveau décriront aujourd'hui tous les
détails de l'événement et vous
révéleront même les prédictions d'un
astrologue pour le couple ils vont
lutter pour cette relation et se regarde
dans les yeux et se tiennent tout le
temps la main ce mariage célébré dans le
monde entier annonce toutefois un grand
changement chez l'une des plus anciennes
familles royales régnante au monde
c'est bien plus qu'un simple mariage
c'est un bouleversement culturel quelle
incroyable histoire d'amour non
c'est le rêve de toutes les petites
filles
depuis l'annoncé officielle de leurs
fiançailles en novembre 2017 il ne se
passe pas une semaine sans que
l'histoire d'amour du prince harry et de
meghan markle ne fasse la une des
journaux à potins
la presse britannique a été brutale
absolument impitoyable et grossière le
harcèlement c'est horrible les
spéculations sur les chances de réussite
de cette union ne se sont pas fait
attendre mais tout porte à croire que
megan est la compagne idéale ferrari et
qu'elle saura s'intégrer dans la famille
royale les journaux change de ton
maintenant que paris a annoncé qu'elle
sera sa femme un mariage comme ça
suscite une énorme couverture des médias
ils ne veulent pas être tenus de dire
vous souvenez vous de ces choses
horribles qu'on a dit somme aiguë et
bien maintenant et nous sommes vraiment
heureux pour eux mais qu'elle a démontré
qu'elle est prête à relever ce défi
en mégane à lui à trouver la femme
parfaite
ils se sont connus par l'entremise d'une
connaissance connue elle ne courais pas
après lui comme un million de femmes en
angleterre qui voyaient en lui le
célibataire le plus convoité à bhl à lui
à meggen partage l'amour du sport on l'a
vu au jeu invictus elle participe à
beaucoup d'oeuvres humanitaires ce cas
oui est fier d'encourager à mes yeux ils
forment une équipe de rêve
c'est vraiment une histoire
hollywoodienne le prince et l'actrice
qui s'unissent et c'est une histoire
merveilleuse mais green était déjà une
célébrité elle comprend ce qu'il faut
faire quand on est le point de mire des
regards
ce n'est pas comme la princesse qui il
vivait dans un autre monde megan connaît
son meilleur angle elle sait comment
être belle et comment se présenter
devant des millions de personnes
depuis trois mois c'est très important
pour moi de ne pas perdre de temps
d'aller de l'avant même si on le fait
discrètement en coulisses ce sur quoi
j'ai concentré mon énergie jusqu'à
présent c'est de rencontrer les bonnes
personnes les bonnes organisations
d'apprendre tout ce que je peux afin de
tirer le meilleur parti possible de
l'occasion qu'on a ici d'apporter du
changement
si déménager dans un autre pays la leaf
est un mariage et se joindre à la
monarchie britannique ne suffisait pas
megan planches de façon spectaculaire
dans cette ville très publique charmant
la population de londres jusqu'à belfast
watts soyons honnêtes les membres de la
famille royale joue un rôle c'est comme
ça megan est déjà formé à sa ayant été
actrice en amérique elle joue un rôle
qu'elle se trouve ou non devant les
caméras
si on regarde ce qui se passe jusqu'à
présent la réaction qu'ils ont reçue à
matignon les gens sont enchantés
avec une approche similaire à celle de
lady diana meg n'explore tranquillement
et discrètement les moyens d'apporter sa
propre contribution en tant que membre
de la famille royale au début de l'année
elle visite les survivants de la
tragédie de la tourbe rainfall et la
mosquée voisine qui a servi de base de
triage lors de l' incendie
shoah montre que megan et courageuse je
fait qu'elle soit halal à tour great flu
10h des pertes de vie pouvant table
temps des circonstances horribles ça
prouve qu'elle n'a pas peur de ce genre
de situation
la visite secrète de meggen aux victimes
de la tour grain fo n'est pas officiel
cette initiative de sa part ouvre les
yeux des critiques qui ont pu douter de
ses motivations
on ne sait pas comment ça a été organisé
il semble que c'était une visite privée
mais ses sorties assez rapidement dans
la presse ça n'a pas nui à son image il
ya donc aussi un côté et relations
publiques à tout ça
le palais a démontré une grande
intelligence dans la façon dont il a
présenté mégane au monde comme une femme
dévouée aux causes humanitaires ça
révèle quand même son courage elle n'a
pas peur des situations difficiles et
elle sait y faire face
va s'intégrer à la famille royale ça va
être intéressant de voir l'influencé
qu'elle va avoir sur la famille legrand
cécité progressiste ce qu'elle veut
faire
c'est une femme très surprenante très
entreprenante très intelligente et très
diplomate c'est aussi une grande
philanthrope elle va donc vouloir parler
des choses qui la passionne ça va rendre
la famille royale beaucoup plus
progressiste est passionné on va avoir
l'impression de connaître ces gens là un
peu mieux
le lien étroit qui unit harry et megan
est tangible le couple amoureux jure que
ça a été le coup de foudre entre eux
d'après une astrologue et médium
renommée calvet nourriture s'était aussi
inscrit dans les étoiles
elle est du signe du lion l'une en
balance ascendant lion
les lions sont très dynamiques ils sont
aussi très séduisant tout le monde le
sait quand il entre dans une pièce on
les voit on les remarques ils ont un
fort magnétisme
une grande partie de son charme lui
vient du signe de la vierge de la lune
en taureau et du capricorne comme à
saint dans ce qui crée une dynamique
intéressante
et vierge ont tendance à être très
minutieux de nature très analytique une
de leurs caractéristiques importantes
c'est qu'ils prennent leurs décisions de
façon très calculée il envisage tout et
ils savent exactement dans quoi ils
s'embarquent
le prince harry c'est lui qui a pris la
décision c'est ce qu'il lui fallait
une des difficultés associées aux
vierges si qu'ils sont parfois très
critique minutieux mais un peu têtu dans
leur approche des choses et leur façon
de faire ils peuvent constater un
problème mais pas nécessairement avoir
envie de faire quoi que ce soit pour le
régler s'ils remarquent que la maison a
besoin d'un peu d'ordre ça ne signifie
pas qu'ils vont ramasser les vêtements
il aura donc fallu une femme passionnée
et volontaires du signe du lion pour
donner à harry l'amour et le soutien
dont il a besoin
les lions sont intéressants un des défis
qui se posent c'est qu'ils aiment être
les premiers il adore être le centre
d'attention est reconnu et apprécié
ce n'est pas autant le cas qu'ils le
voudraient ils peuvent devenir un peu
agressif un peu autoritaire ils
manifestent parfois de la colère dans
cette dynamique il arrive aussi qu'ils
soient envahissant
je vois des choses intéressantes dans
leurs tableaux numérologique encore plus
que dans leur carte astrologique il a un
chemin de vie numéro 1 est elle un
chemin de vie numéro 4 il est très fort
et indépendant c'est un pionnier il est
destiné à faire les choses différemment
il est censé commencer des choses que
personne d'autre n'a jamais fait
auparavant
pour elle maintenant c'est un chemin de
vie numéro 4 qui est centrée sur la
structure sur l'appui elle peut donc lui
offrir ce soutien là bien qu'elle trace
aussi la voix dans plusieurs domaines
différents
je crois qu'ils se connaissaient dans
une autre vie il ya ici des choses
vraiment intéressantes
ça ne me surprendrait pas qu'ils aient
déclaré avoir eu le coup de foudre que
tout leur avait paru si naturel
alors que l'excitation monte pour le
mariage du prince harry et de meghan
markle il est impossible d'ignorer le
vent de fraîcheur qu'apporte ce couple
royal britannique non traditionnels
les mariages royaux joue toujours un
rôle important pour réaffirmer la
dynastie comme exemple de la puissance
et de la stabilité de la famille royale
ça se veut l'incarnation de ce que le
pays représente
ses parents étaient divorcés et se
démener pour réussir à hollywood quand
une actrice a du succès à hollywood on
sait tous qu'elle faisait preuve elle a
dû traverser
c'est tellement difficile
ce n'est pas la mariée royale la plus
conventionnelle c'est une divorcé de
race mixte ses relations antérieures
n'ont pas duré et c'est sûrement créer
une carapace elle a vécu beaucoup de
choses elle avait le monde ait connu
d'autres cultures certains journaux ne
la montre est pas nécessairement en
première page il disait qu'elle ne plaît
pas à leur auditoire à la télévision et
dans les médias en ligne par contre
c'était génial la réaction était
excellente ça laisse entendre qu'il ya
une division en fonction de l'âge dans
la façon dont on la perçoit
il ne fait aucun doute que ce mariage
royal va être bénéfique pour l'économie
britannique
le royaume uni va avoir une bonne presse
dans le monde entier grâce à ça les
membres de la famille royale de cette
génération là vont jouer une sorte de
rôle diplomatique discret c'est déjà le
cas ils vont souvent mettre de l'avant
une approche plus souple de la
diplomatie au milieu des négociations
sur le breakbeat on a vu la famille
royale faire des tournées en europe pour
montrer un visage différent du royaume
uni
il n'y a pas de famille royale aux états
unis c'est comme ça il n'y en a jamais
eu il y à beaucoup d'autres familles
royales dans le monde une essai c'est la
plus grande d'entre elles
voire une américaine se marier dans ce
genre de famille ça dit oh oui on a
réussi on fait partie de tout ça nous
aussi
si le protocole royal se relâche pour my
own et harry c'est bien parce qu'il ya
eu des précédents d'autres avant eux ont
lutté pour en arriver à cette nouvelle
ère de mariages royaux
la reine elizabeth ii a dû affronter une
opposition farouche quand elle a révélé
son intention d'épouser le prince philip
de grèce et du danemark
et encore rappelons que vaut son prix
cette union royale médiatisée a donné le
ton pour la suite comme en témoigne
l'union scruté à la loupe du prince
william avec kate middleton une compagne
de l'université kate une roturière est
vite devenu la cible des critiques et
des paparazzi
mais kate ont même intenté une poursuite
quand on l'a photographié sa nue je
crois cependant que ce qui inquiétait le
plus kate c'est la gérance des
paparazzis dans la vie de ses enfants
elle a aussi beaucoup poussé
trois des quatre enfants de la reine
elizabeth et ans divorcée qui aurait pu
nier le bonheur à ce jeune couple le
mariage a non seulement reçu l'aval de
la famille royale mais aussi celui de
deux milliards de personnes dans le
monde
[Musique]
pendant longtemps l'idée de la famille
empoisonné la vie de la famille royale à
l'époque victorienne la monarchie
c'était essentiellement une famille
royale
c'est devenu le modèle de la famille
dans ce pays
albert victoria et leur enfant était
considéré comme la famille idéale et
c'était le produit que la monarchie
offrait incarner ce genre de royautés
familiale
ça a duré jusqu'aux années 80 et 90
quand les mariages des enfants de la
reine se sont effondrés
l'idée que la famille royale était un
modèle auquel on devait tous aspirent et
qu'elle reflétait ce qu'on vivait et
qu'elle représentait quelque chose a
commencé à poser problème
l'image de marque ne correspondait plus
aux produits et il est devenu très
toxique pour la monarchie cela dit on
assiste ces dernières années à une sorte
de réaffirmation de la famille
ont tiré des leçons des unions royales
du passé ils ont vu leur mère
malheureuse dans son mariage est décidé
ne voulait pas vivre ça
william et kate forme une jeune famille
typique avec trois enfants
il ya aussi
on sent que les notions de la famille du
couple font d'un retour ils se rendent
compte qu'ils peuvent être heureux mais
que c'est à eux de faire leur bonheur je
pense que la reine elizabeth a fini par
l'admettre elle aussi c'est pourquoi
elle s'est montrée si compréhensive qui
était devenue la duchesse de cambridge
et la première roturière depuis 16 160 à
se marier dans la famille royale
britannique
en fait plusieurs membres de la famille
royale ont déjà imposé des roturiers
charles s'est marié à une roturière une
divorcée sa première femme était aussi
roturière certes elle faisait partie de
l'aristocratie n'est pas d'une famille
royale william et la princesse mary est
aussi aux mariés des roturiers
d'abord il ne reste plus de presse
allemande
il faudrait beaucoup de chance pour
arriver à trouver un membre disponibles
d'une autre famille royale en espérant
qu'il se crée un lien amoureux par
ailleurs je crois que cette époque est
révolue il n'y a pas que le choix de
william qui a fait tourner les têtes
il y a aussi la robe de mariée
maintenant classique de kate dessinée
par sarah burton d'alexander mcqueen
cette robe a conquis les critiques de
mode du monde entier
qu'elle s'est inspirée de la robe de
grace kelly qui avait une écharpe en
satin et une traîne de neuf pieds c'est
une vraie robe de princesse
l'échec du mariage du prince charles et
de diana est devenue l'obsession des
médias quand celle ci a révélé la
liaison de son mari avec camilla parker
bowles dans une entrevue choc
personne n'aurait cru au début que la
jeune lady diana spencer a serait
bientôt des années dans la tourmente à
cause de l'échec de son mariage en fait
les noces de charles et diana semblait
sorti tout droit d'un film de disney
avec la robe de conte de fées a sorti
de la princesse diana reflète pour moi
les années 80 c'était une robe une fente
en taffetas irisé elle était très
dramatique avec sa traîne de 25 pieds
qui ne rentraient pas dans le carrosse
c'était superbe et aussi intemporel
hélas le mariage de diana n'a pas duré
comme c'était à prévoir charles a fini
par épouser camilla après avoir attendu
l'approbation de la reine pendant des
années
charles et camilla importe la charge du
passé pour la façon dont la relation a
évolué dans ses premiers jours les
applications pour diana et tout le reste
charles et camilla étaient tous deux
divorcés ils n'ont pas eu droit à tout
le cérémonial des mariages royaux
traditionnel la célébration de leur
union signalait toutefois que les temps
avaient changé meghan markle n'a donc
pas s'inquiéter parce qu'il s'agit de
ses deuxièmes noces
les unions des enfants de la reine n'ont
pas été couronnées de succès quand la
reine a su pour mégane et à huy et qui
lui a dit que c'était sérieux il
semblerait qu'elle était très heureuse
pour lui tout ce qu'elle veut c'est que
ces enfants et bien sûr ses petits
enfants soit heureux
leur bonheur étant au centre de cet
événement façon maintenant aux
célébrations et aux conjectures sur la
robe et les chapeaux les correspondants
royaux et les maisons de paris n'ont pas
cessé de spéculer sur l'identité du
design choisi
son amie canadienne jessica maroni a
déjà été sa styliste l aide sans doute
mais guenat choisir le style de sa robe
parce qu'on sait qu'elle s'occupe aussi
de mariage c'est la femme de ben moroni
le fils de l'ex premier ministre brian
mulroney et ils seront sans doute
présents au mariage je suppose que
jessica a travaillé pour mégane à
maintes reprises c'est donc la personne
idéale pour l'appuyer en ce moment
personne ne connaît mieux que les
dessinatrice de mode salé de niall
d'année sous la pression de concevoir la
robe de mariée parfaite pour des
célébrités ayant récemment uni leurs
forces avec la designer italienne
arrosez-les l'aespa novaes pour leur
nouvelle collection elles savent ce
qu'il faut pour que la mariée bris lors
de son grand jour si c'était un mariage
de célébrités elles pourraient être plus
fidèle à elle même souligné sa
personnalité et porter ce qu'elle veut
comme c'est un mariage royal et qu'il y
a des règles à suivre il va aussi lui
falloir tenir compte du lieu la chapelle
saint georges elle va respecter la reine
et les règles
il y aura probablement un jupon ou un
autre accessoire sur la traîne de sa
robe pour ajouter à l'effet dramatique
parce qu'au moment où elle va entrer
dans la chapelle saint georges tout le
monde va l'observer il va falloir que ce
soit saisie sans vraiment intéressant
après le mariage du prince harry et de
meggen marco de voir quel effet la
fièvre meggen va avoir et à quel moment
la robe de mariée c'est ce qu'un
designer peut faire de mieux dans toute
sa carrière ça va lancer une nouvelle
tendance vestimentaire
si l'histoire se répète ça va se
produire immédiatement comme pour kate
del moment kate est sortie en robe de
mariée avec des manches les manches sur
les robes de mariées sont devenus très
très populaire
la robe de kate a été copiée bien des
fois en changeant le format et les
matériaux maiden sort sous les feux de
la rampe le 19 mai et dévoile sa robe de
mariée à un milliard de spectateurs
provoquant la frénésie dans le monde de
la mode
tout le monde va vouloir s'habiller
comme megan au moment où elle s'est
montrée le jour de son mariage s'est
photographiée télévisée elle va avoir un
effet immense comme pour tout autre
célébrité mais elle c'est une princesse
ce qui va faire une différence énorme
mais il s'est bâti une solide réputation
en matière de tendances et de styles et
l'industrie de la mode lui porte une
grande attention
ce qui va arriver c'est que les
créateurs de mode qui font du
prêt-à-porter vont en produire
rapidement et laisser leurs stocks
s'écoulent et
sa touche personnelle à un autre
vêtement
en tant qu'actrice mais galles était
déjà reconnue pour son élégance
maintenant qu'elle est membre de la
famille royale son style à la fois
accessible et soigné fait augmenter les
ventes de vêtements à l'échelle
planétaire c'est bien plus qu'un simple
mariage c'est un bouleversement culturel
mégane va conserver son style individuel
chic et décontracté il va même en être
rehaussés parce que là maintenant accès
à toutes les marques du monde en vérité
les gens vont s'attarder aux tendances
mode mais ils vont aussi être à l'affût
de ce qui se passe culturellement qui
est là qui d'autres acceptent ce mariage
est la nouvelle famille royale
le design des robes a toujours joué un
rôle essentiel dans les mariages royaux
surtout lorsque deux nations sont
impliqués au moyen-âge et au début de la
période moderne les mariages royaux
était un outil pour créer des alliances
diplomatiques
c'était donc très important la robe de
la reine elizabeth ii symboliser son
pouvoir sont la grande bretagne et le
common word mais plusieurs l'ont jugé
trop constante at war si peu de temps
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
c'étaient deux ans après la seconde
guerre mondiale et les gens faisaient
toujours la queue pour obtenir des
rations les monarques devait faire très
attention de ne pas donner l'impression
que le dépenser trop d'argent alors que
le peuple du royaume uni traverser
encore de grandes difficultés
on dit maintenant une époque très
différentes mais je crois que megan
entretient aussi un peu cette façon de
penser
une robe de mariée royale devrait plaire
aux gens résisté à l'épreuve de la mode
et être superbe vue de dos elle devient
le symbole de cette union politiquement
et socialement et passe ainsi à
l'histoire
espérons que megan n'a pas trop ressenti
de pression
avant les journaux et les caméras de
télévision les ambassadeurs qui
assistaient aux mariages royaux écrivait
ensuite à la cour de leur pays pour
décrire la splendeur de la cérémonie
c'était une indication de la force de la
puissance et de la richesse du pays hôte
ce mariage est en fait un moment de
grand bonheur pour la nation
le brésil a fait naître un pessimisme
envahissant les prévisions économiques
ne sont pas très encourageantes
bien que la robe de meggen est attiré
toute l'attention les invités n'ont pas
eu la tâche facile non plus au moment de
se choisir une tenue
qu'elle se comporte un mariage royal
c'est difficile non c'est probablement
la tâche la plus ardue qu'on puisse
avoir dans cette vie vestimentaire le
chapeau est une partie essentielle de la
tenue féminine pour les américains c'est
une décision très complexe portez un
chapeau ou il pas emporter telle est la
question les britanniques adore les
chapeaux et un tel événement
l'illustrent parfaitement le style des
chapeaux est une chose dont tout le
monde parle dans ses grandes occasions
encore plus s'il s'agit d'un mariage
royal grands ou petits la rejouer trois
plats ou incliné il ajoute une touche de
fantaisie aux tenues des invités sans
pour autant leur permettre d'éclipser la
mariée
j'imagine beaucoup de chapeaux de
capuchon de couleur pastel
et beaucoup de perles je crois que les
américains vont prendre exemple sur la
personnalité de megan comme pour dire
c'est ce qu'on est l es des nôtres et
six corps présente également
un coût n'est pas la première actrice
née la première américaine à se marier
dans une famille royale
quand l'actrice américaine grace kelly
épouser le prince rainier iii de monaco
en 1956 la principauté traverse une
époque politiquement et financièrement
turbulente l'équilibré l'élégance de la
nouvelle princesse apporte un vent d'air
frais à ce petit pays est une diversion
des mieux accueillie elle n'est
peut-être pas de sang bleu mais elle
fait tout de même partie de la royauté
hollywoodienne la robe de mariée de
grace kelly est vraiment intemporel
c'était un cadeau de son ami faire le
noir aux rsa a porté la robe d'amérique
je crois et ils l'ont modifié elle avait
de jupons en tartare et de la dentelle
de bruxelles de 125 ans cette robe a
vaincu l'épreuve du temps je trouve que
c'est une des plus belles
si je devais comparer mes gars à une
épouse royale du passé ce serait
peut-être
deux actrices et vedettes de hollywood
qui se sont jointes à une institution
très différentes en se mariant
ce qu'il y avait de merveilleux c'est
que les scories c'est qu'elle était
empathique et bienveillante le grand
public qui tombe amoureux des gens comme
ça
c'est utile d'établir une comparaison
avec la princesse grace quand elle s'est
mariée dans la famille princière
monégasque
elle a dû abandonner la vie qu'elle
avait toujours connu
et les venues de rauly woods pour
s'installer dans une toute petite
principauté monaco mais dans son cas ça
fait connaître monaco au monde entier
grâce kelly a peut être ouvert la voie à
meggen mais la jeune marié devra tracer
son propre chemin dans cette nouvelle
vie meggen n'a pas besoin de faire
connaître le royaume uni et la famille
royale est très célèbre mais tout comme
la princesse grace a apporté un peu de
magie à la famille princière et à soupe
ou dhr et de la poussière des toiles je
crois qu'on va voir la même chose avec
megan
mégane est un esprit libre elle va faire
preuve de circonspection pour ce qui est
des choses qu'elles acceptent de faire
tout en cherchant à aller au bout de ses
convictions
ça devrait donner un mélange intéressant
cette fois ci
on pourrait dire que big n se soucie
beaucoup de la santé de la bonne
alimentation son ancien blog fatigue
encourager l'adoption de modes de vie
sains
j'aurais voulu partager tellement
d'autres choses j'ai vraiment un amour
naturel profond des voyages et de la
nourriture
mariage ou pas megan s'assure de
consommer des aliments sains et des jus
de fruits et des légumes au quotidien
meggen s'est mise en excellente forme
récemment avec une combinaison de régime
végétalien cinq jours par semaine et de
jus les options végétalienne est
végétarienne sont de plus en plus
populaires et faciles d'accès surtout
dans les restaurants suivre un régime
végétalien bien structuré
ça signifie bénéficier d'une plus grande
quantité de fibres et de magnésium ses
habitudes alimentaires et sa seule
vision de la vie ont également d'état
sur harry le prince semblait en grande
forme à la proche de son mariage
quand on suit une diète végétalienne ou
qu'on change de régime alimentaire c'est
toujours plus efficace si les deux
conjoints y participent
de la même façon un effort pour obtenir
un changement physique peut être
entravés quand un des conjoints ne
s'implique pas complètement sir harry
profite de ce que fait mme eagleson peut
être qu'une bonne chose ils peuvent tous
deux se sentir confiants quant à leur
mariage et leur avenir en plus de bien
s'alimenter meillonnas aussi fait du
yoga l'une de ses habitudes quotidiennes
c'est principalement grâce à sa mère
qu'il enseigne à los angeles
le yoga peut s'avérer très bénéfique
pour quelqu'un avant le mariage si on
pense au stress et à l'anxiété liée à sa
planification
le yoga est très relaxant c'est bon pour
le flux sanguin à la santé mentale et le
stress
inspire
indécent détends toi
le yoga peut seulement avoir un effet
positif
selon mon expérience c'est
habituellement la flexibilité ou la
mobilité l'amplitude des mouvements
d'une personne ou sa capacité
d'emprunter certaines positions qui ont
le plus d'incidence sur l'efficacité
d'un régime d'exercice
on se détend
nous sommes en mai de nombreux membres
de la maison royale s'affairent au
château de windsor qui grouille
d'activités résidence de monarque
anglais et britanniques depuis près de
milan c'est ici que doit avoir lieu le
mariage du prince harry et de meghan
markle dont l'histoire d'amour féerique
à capter l'attention des médias du monde
entier
les hôtels sont bondés
carpostal tasse à leur effigie construit
au xième siècle par guillaume le
conquérant le château de windsor est la
plus ancienne demeure royale habité
d'europe son histoire est si riche et
longue qu'il faut tout contingent
d'historiens et de conservateurs pour
administrer le site le château de
windsor a été construit sur les ordres
de guillaume le conquérant qui envahit
l'angleterre en 1066 il veut vieux
palais royal dans ce qui s'appelle
maintenant aux douanes sort qu'on nous
mette encore simplement windsor à
l'époque william a décidé de construire
son palais sur cette affleurements sur
la colline élite immense d'ailleurs
c'est en fait le plus grand château
habité dans nombre avec ses terres à
majestueux ses intérieurs ornementé et
ses illustres anciens occupants ce
château et son histoire donne un tout
nouveau sens au dicton si les murs
pouvaient parler est ce que tous les
rois et toutes les reines d'angleterre y
ont vécu un moment donné et c'est l'une
des résidences préféré de notre ville le
coût de ce mariage royal est un des
sujets qui font le plus parler
les organisateurs d'événements estime
qu'avec la sécurité cette célébration
pourrait occasionner des dépenses de
plus de 42 millions de dollars on vit
dans une période très grave ou le
terrorisme sévit un grand mariage à
londres ça devient un cauchemar pour la
sécurité pour un mariage moins important
à windsor et les possibles de sécuriser
la zone le château de windsor peut être
isolé les mesures de sécurité sont
vraiment exagéré
l'accès à windsor va être fermé la
tragédie voiture en calèche ou à pied
dans les rues de windsor ça peut se
contenir ce n'est pas un cauchemar comme
ça ce serait à londres à ce qu'il y a
une longue route à faire du palais de
buckingham jusqu'à l'abbaye de
westminster il faut la sécuriser ça
signifie beaucoup de policiers sur le
terrain et qui paie tout ça les
contribuables c'est beaucoup d'argent
la famille royale prend en charge la
plupart des éléments traditionnels du
mariage meighen grandement admiré pour
son style vestimentaire aurait elle-même
payé sa robe ce sont toutefois les
contribuables britanniques qui doivent
débourser pour l'aspect le plus coûteux
d'entre tous la sécurité le climat la
reine et le prince de galles ont dit
qu'ils prennent en charge le coût du
mariage et de la réception les
contribuables n'auront pas à payer ça
mais la plus grosse facture pour les
mariages royaux c'est la sécurité ça
coûtait 10 millions de livres pour le
mariage de william et de kate
les réunions du g20 l'assemblée des
nations unies et les jeux olympiques
sont tous des exemples concrets de
déploiement de sécurité intense et
coûteux de cette nature pour beaucoup il
est étonnant qu'un mariage entre dans
cette catégorie
ne minimisons pas le mariage de mai
dernier certes ce n'est pas la bei de
westminster ni la cathédrale saint paul
personnellement je ne crois pas que ça
nuise beaucoup à son retentissement pour
la sécurité par contre c'est beaucoup
plus facile le château de windsor et
déjà une zone sécurisée les mesures de
surveillance ont défini il faut
seulement les réviser sur ce plan c'est
une très bonne décision
la cérémonie doit inévitablement avoir
moins d'ampleur à windsor
parce que c'est un lieu très différent
du centre de londres mais la sécurité
reste primordiale
au château de windsor c'est plus petit
le joli la situation est facile à
maîtriser la menace n'est donc pas aussi
grande à windsor comme ce serait le cas
dans le centre de londres
plusieurs s'empresse toutefois de
souligner que les mesures de sécurité ne
servent pas uniquement à protéger la
famille royale et ses invités mais aussi
le grand nombre de britanniques et
d'étrangers qui se présentent à la
célébration
ce déploiement exige une coordination
incroyable il comprend la surveillance
par drones des escadrons de police à
cheval et des contrôles de sécurité
comme dans les aéroports et les routes
sont fermées à partir de 8 heures du
matin il ya tellement présence policière
on n'a jamais vu ça avant
on ferme pendant le mariage pour ouvrir
probablement vers une heure ou deux avec
92 mille personnes qui descendent la rue
du parc
j'espère que le coût va être compensé
par l'essor du commerce touristique en
grande bretagne à la suite du mariage
royal c'est certainement ce qu'on a vu
en demies ans
c'est génial
les médias du monde les genres
on attend de 25 à 40 mille personnes sur
cette clause de partout mexique brésil
norvège japon etats unis australie ah
oui et mes gueux n'aurait pu se marier
dans la prestigieuse abbaye de
westminster mais ils ont demandé la
permission de la reine pour que leur
mariage soit célébré dans la chapelle
saint georges du château de windsor
leur décision a éveillé la curiosité du
public car elle soulignait la grande
importance de cet endroit pour le couple
princier tout comme pour son altesse
royale elle-même
le château de windsor est
essentiellement la maison de la reine le
palais de buckingham c'est le bureau si
elle passe la soirée quelque part c'est
probablement à windsor derrière les murs
du château il y a les appartements
d'état elle a ses appartements privés et
c'est comme ça qu'elle vit
les funérailles de la mère du père et de
la soeur de la reine elizabeth ii ont
toutes eu lieu à la chapelle saint
georges le deuxième mariage du père de
harry a été célébrée tout près au wales
ou grandes mais c'est à saint georges
que s'est déroulé le service de prières
et de consécration pour le prince
charles et la duchesse de cornouailles
c'est considéré comme le siège de la
famille royale c'est là depuis l'époque
de guillaume le conquérant
quand la famille a décidé de changer son
nom germanique de saxe-cobourg-gotha
pendant la première guerre mondiale on
lui cherche un nom certains ont suggéré
des noms d'autres fois comme plantagenêt
est ce tu as he
sees windsor qui a été choisi parce que
ça évoque les fondations solides de la
famille royale les fondations solides du
château
ces liens familiaux historiques font
certes partie de ce qui ramène harry au
château de windsor mais son attachement
pour ce lieu remonte à son enfance et
est d'autant plus profond c'est ici que
le prince a grandi qu'il a appris à
monter à cheval et qu'il venait visiter
sa grand-mère au sortir de l'école
[Musique]
harry était basé à windsor avec son
régiment il est aussi allé à l'école au
coin de la rue au collège iten
apparemment mégane et lui ont passé
beaucoup de temps ce faire la cour à
fribourg qui était autrefois le domaine
du duc de windsor le prince édouard vite
c'est vraiment génial qu'ils aient
décidé de faire le mariage comme ça ça
fait changement de la tradition
encore une fois ça montre que ce n'est
pas un couple royal normal il souhaite
changer les choses et tenir ça ou alors
parce que c'est plus intime
nous sommes persuadés qu'avec un trésor
national comme windsor les gens ne sont
que trop heureux de faire un petit
effort en échange d'une expérience
historique inestimable
[Musique]
il n'y a pas que le château qu'ils
soient riches en histoire
le côté du bac jeu dans lequel il est
situé l un des plus beaux contes et
d'angleterre
c'est aussi l'un des comptes est
originellement formés et gouvernés par
les normands au moyen âge il a également
été reconnu comme compter royal par la
reine en 1957
[Musique]
la reine est aussi il est très à l'aise
il faut se rappeler qu'elle a déjà 92
ans au moment de son mariage c'est assez
vieux le prince philippe à presque 81 18
ans je pense
doivent penser au reste de la famille
pas seulement eux mêmes le banquier est
de toute évidence un excellent choix
comme on vient de le découvrir la
famille royale a des liens personnels
unique avec la région les études les
sports les fréquentations amoureuses la
famille kate middleton est originaire du
braque chez sa mère et son père vivent
toujours à proximité will et kate ont
même été aperçus par des clients du pub
de prat kim favori des gens de la région
pour ses viandes de gibier frêche et ses
boissons locales
le podium est la quintessence des pubs
anglais on y sert des bières qui sombre
et c'est ici et de la nourriture qui a
été élevé ici dans les bois qui nous
entoure on a près de 9000 acres de
terres agricoles et boisées ce qui nous
distingue particulièrement
notre garde-manger arrière c'est toutes
les denrées et le gibier sauvage qu'on
peut manger au coeur de notre menu il y
à notre philosophie et notre culture
soit l'agriculture et l'élevage avec
compassion on est très axé sur les
aliments sauvages et les plats
typiquement britanniques
viennent ici depuis des années parce
qu'ils habitent juste un peu plus haut
sur cette route c'est un endroit où il
se sent en privé ils ont l'impression de
pouvoir se divertir avec des amis et
leurs familles et ils savent qu'on va
prendre soin d'eux
quelques membres de la famille royale
viennent ici
william kate est aussi à oui ils sont
tous venus à un moment donné ils se
mélangent aux autres clients et ça soit
tout simplement une table certains
peuvent les regarder en se posant des
questions mais eux
l'autre jour ils ont déplacé les tables
et commencer à jouer aux fléchettes
il ya probablement une très grande
différence qui s'applique à la famille
royale c'est de l'histoire plutôt que de
la nostalgie plusieurs trouve que
l'histoire ne suscite pas d'émotions la
nostalgie oui ce qu'on a vécu avec ses
grands parents sa famille ses amis ça
fait
déballer tas d'émotions
on a beaucoup parlé du mariage de bègles
et à oui parce que bien sûr une partie
de la famille vit ici
je pense que ça remonte le moral des
gens autrefois je ne m'intéressais pas
la famille royale mais j'ai appris
quelque chose ici en faisant la
connaissance de carole et michael
middleton
il est vraiment à stimuler le moral et
l'enthousiasmé des gens c'est une
famille bien équilibrée très axé sur la
famille très unie et aux liens solides
leurs voeux de mariage à peine prononcée
le prince harry et meghan markle
continue de redéfinir la monarchie en
tenant une réception de boue qui rompt
avec la tradition
d'après ce que j'ai entendu dire on
attend 600 invités au service nuptiale
mais je sais qu'une réception royale
privé est prévu en fin de soirée ce sera
sans doute une petite réception qui
suivra la tradition avec 200 invités
je pense que mengele respecter ça pour
la famille elle va démontrer sa
personnalité avec la réception ça va
être élégant avec toutes les traditions
royales du passé de leur famille on peut
s'attendre à l'inattendu
je crois qu'il y aura beaucoup
d'ornement
mégane et son prince se sont appliqués
dans toutes les étapes de la conception
du menu et ont même participé à des
dégustations
couple royal a goûté à tous il a
supervisé chaque détail
ils ont également demandé que chaque
plein soit créée à partir d' autant
d'ingrédients locaux et saisonniers que
possible le chef royal mark flanagan et
son équipe sont ravis de cette demande
car c'est justement le moment de l'année
où les produits saisonniers britanniques
elles sont le plus succulent
le couple a voulu s'assurer qu'on
utilise autant que possible des produits
locaux et de saison pour l'ensemble du
menu
le beau temps récents nous est vraiment
à satisfaire cette requête
une grande partie des denrées fraîches
proviennent en fait et des domaines de
l'art elle difficile de trouver plus
locale que ça on n'a pas souvent
l'occasion dans la vie de préparer un
mariage royal
c'est donc très spécial le soin et
l'attention aux détails sont essentiels
c'est vraiment très excitant
les invités dégustent débouchés et de la
nourriture en bol facile à manger
pendant qu'ils se mêlent et discutent
plus important encore harry meyen
peuvent en faire autant ici je prépare
les truffes ou red un délicieux mélange
de chocolat au lait de kirsch
ce sont des petites douceurs typique
pour nos réceptions et soirées privées
quand les invités sont convaincus qu'ils
ne pourront jamais avalé une bouchée
plus c'est l'heure de découper le gâteau
de mariage qui comme tout le reste n'a
rien de conventionnel
mais gannett en fine bouche elle a
sûrement eu un peu d'affluence mais je
ne sais pas si le gâteau sera sans
gluten c'est à la chef pâtissière
californian clairac qu'on a demandé de
préparer le gâteau au citron et à la
fleur de sureau garni d'un glaçage à la
crème au beurre et décoré de fleurs
fraîches comestibles mais qu'elle a
choisi un gâteau un peu plus américain
que les gâteaux de mariage royal typique
du passé on dit qu'il va être garni de
crème au beurre et au citron
je les imagine coup pendant ce gâteau et
tout le monde en dégustant un morceau ça
va être génial le réputé chef pâtissier
du prestigieux hôtel du véhicule d'un
steak sauce antonio san salonais
comprend bien l'importance de réussir le
gâteau de mariage
j'adore l'inspiration floral avec la
fleur de sureau j'adore les combinaisons
de saveurs ça évoque beaucoup plus la
saison étant donné qu'il s'agit d'un
mariage de prata le texas est bien loin
du château de windsor mais certaines
traditions demeurent universel dans les
société imprégnée de coutume ancestrale
mon interprétation d'un gâteau de
mariage anglais traditionnel ça serait
un gâteau aux fruits très dense
avec des couche de confiture de fruits à
l'intérieur et couvert d'un fondant ou
d'une pâte d'amande
il reste à voir si le gâteau de mariage
d'inspiration saisonnière des railleries
et mégane lancera une nouvelle tradition
royale
grâce aux médias sociaux nous pouvons
toutefois parier que nouvelles tendances
mondial va émerger dans l'industrie du
gâteau de mariage
la façon dont les choses se font
aujourd'hui beaucoup des demandes de
gâteaux sont inspirés de ce qui se voit
dans les médias sociaux
je suis sûr que les petites filles six
machines de quoi aurait l'air leur
gâteau de mariage quand le grand jour
leurs jours magiques va arriver il ne
fait aucun doute que les goûts de mégane
ont inspiré ce gâteau de mariage mais
ses racines californienne s'harmonise
parfaitement avec le meilleur du
printemps au royaume uni
[Musique]
l'aube se lève sur les majestueux
terrain du château de windsor le samedi
19 mai 2018 un matin pas comme les
autres
la petite ville de windsor et maintenant
ornée de banderoles et de drapeaux qui
déborde de fierté britannique
les rues de pavés et la longue promenade
du château se remplissent de gens venus
de terre très très lointaine pour voir
un conte de fées devenir réalité
alors qu'avance dans la chapelle la
famille royale et les invités célèbres
dans les clous ni et les beckham le
monde retient son souffle dans l'attenté
de son premier coup d'oeil à la mariée
peu après la jeune américaine qui a su
s'imposer à ras du mode parcours la
longue promenade du château historique
sous les acclamations de milliers de
personnes
le moment tant attendu est enfin arrivé
dans une robe royal à couper le souffle
de la designer britannique hitler weight
watchers pour givenchy mégane se rend
lentement à la chapelle afin d'y
retrouver son prince devant l'autel
ban
il
n'y a pas
une personne
c'est une cérémonie remplie d'amour et
de tendresse
harry
le
prince ému aux larmes
une congrégation rempli de joie et un
serment scellée par un baiser
alors que le soleil se couche sur le
château de windsor tout le monde peut
croire un instant que les condos qui
existe et que l'amour conquiert tout
[Musique]
cette célébration de mariages a rompu
avec une grande partie de la tradition
royale comme en ont témoigné les camions
serment de la nourriture aux invités
tard dans la nuit c'est un signe des
temps mais ça en dit long sur le couple
royal le plus récemment marié du royaume
uni j'ai bien hâte de voir tout ce qu'il
va accomplir en tant que duchesse je
pense qu'elle apporte un vent de
nouveauté et qu'elle va être une joueuse
l'équipe crucial dans la famille royal
army et meggen semble rompre avec le
protocole quand bon leur semble mais en
conservant l'élégance et la grâce qu'on
associe à la monarchie elle va peut-être
trouvé ça un peu ennuyeux de faire
partie de la famille royale parce
qu'elle est habituée à l'éclat des
plateaux de tournage et qu'elle a été
vedette d'une émission de netflix août
elle a toujours eu une attirance pour ce
genre de célébrités si elle pense que ça
va être pareil d'être membre de la
famille royale ce n'est vraiment pas le
cas le peuple britannique y gagnant
meggen une femme travailleuse et
consciencieuse qui a les pieds bien sur
terre elle sera indéniablement une
source d'inspiration pour bien des gens
dans son nouveau rôle je serais déçu que
megan adopte un style très classique
mais je pense que c'est inévitable elle
va être encore capable de porter ce
qu'elle veut à la campagne avec harry ou
pendant leurs nombreux voyages dans ces
situations là elle va être elle-même
avec son style bohème habituel mais il
va falloir qu'elle se débarrasse pour de
bon de ses jeans déchirés la monarchie
britannique a déjà subi une
transformation en ce 21ème siècle avec
le mariage du prince william et de kate
middleton ils ont réussi à faire les
choses un peu différemment
bien que william soit ni laitiers direct
du trône et ses enfants aussi
on aura le roi church est peut être la
reine camilla avant leur wigan mais la
reine catherine
c'est ainsi que fonctionne la famille
royale
c'est une monarchie constitutionnelle et
c'est ce qui va se produire
certains vont soutenir que ce sont les
plus jeunes membres de la famille qui
ont un rôle plus important à jouer pour
faire avancer la monarchie dans le 21e
siècle ce sont eux qui ont le contact
avec la génération suivante
le prince charles a souvent fait des
commentaires surprenants pour les
gardiens du protocole entre autres
concernant son désir de transformer le
palais de buckingham en hôtel à
l'occasion
charme sera toutefois le prochain a
accédé au trône et il est tenu
d'observer un certain décorum il n'est
peut-être pas en mesure de prendre les
mêmes risques qu'un de ses fils les gens
pensent qu'il va régner comme s'il était
encore prince de galles avoir une
opinion sur diverses questions se mêler
politique ce passionné pour certaines
causes être une sorte de livre ouvert
relativement parlant il sait pourtant
que ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça
quand il va être roi ça va à l'encontre
du rôle de monarque constitutionnel et
il va devoir se taire je pense qu'il ya
chez lui un sentiment croissant
d'acceptation qu'elle en est conscient
il ne fait quand même aucun doute que ça
va être difficile pour lui de suivre les
pas de sa mère c'est ce qui va se passer
tout ça est très imprévisible
c'est le prince william qui a dit un
jour modernisation est un mot difficile
employés auprès de la monarchie parce
que c'est tout le contraire de la
modernité c'est antix historique ses
traditionnels en fait pour que la
monarchie persiste et continue de
prospérer il faut qu'elle se modernise
la reine le reconnaît c'est pour ça
qu'on a vu sur twitter annoncer des
choses sur facebook et joué dans une
parodie avec son fils pour les eu une
victime avec les obama c'est une façon
pour elle de se connecter à la société
moderne elle se rend sans doute compte
que le bréslien pour l'avenir c'est bien
sûr la génération suivante de la famille
royale les enfants de jarry et meg ne
grandiront sous la surveillance qui
découle de leur appartenance à la
famille royale
nous sommes cependant convaincu que mes
jeunes apportera une nouvelle énergie à
la famille et conservera un peu de son
côté zen californien avec les futurs
bébés royaux vous imaginez j'adorerais
ça qu'ils portent des t-shirts des
guns'n roses c'est qu'il soit super
américain
je me demande parfois s'il va devenir
plus conservatrice si elle a un enfant
c'est garanti elle s'est mariée dans la
famille royale mais il faut aussi se
rappeler que le prince harry là et poser
pour elle elle l'a épousé pour lui ça
n'a rien à voir avec le protocole la
famille ce qui compte c'est leur amour
je pense qu'elle fait partie de ceux qui
sont assez fort pour rester cohérent
elle est forte d'esprit elle va
s'habiller comme elle veut s'habiller
c'est une bouffée d'air frais pour tout
le monde elle va apporter le look mais
marco aux îles britanniques
je pense qu'elle va conserver son style
on va la voir portée de superbe manteau
avec de jolis petits sacs à main
malgré les spéculations disgracieuses
des trolls de l'internet sur la couleur
de peau des futurs enfants de harry
meyen le reste du monde accepte avec
joie les différences dans cette lignée
royale
elle reflète le royaume uni
d'aujourd'hui après tout et ouvre la
voie aux autres membres de la famille
royale qui tombe amoureux de soi disant
roturier
ça va être excitant de voir ces enfants
là à moitié américains à moitié anglais
grandir dans la famille royale
cette relation entre art et
ça n'aurait pas passé si facilement il y
a 20 ans on savait déjà que la famille
royale avait évolué il fallait que ça
change c'était dépasser leur attitude à
l'égard de la vie s'est actualisée et ça
va s'améliorer encore plus maintenant
avec des gens comme william
leur bonheur compte plus que le
protocole dans cette histoire c'est un
progrès fantastique
je pense qu'ils veulent que ça dure le
fait de ne pas avoir signé le contrat
prénuptial en dit long il semble
vraiment se dire j'aime cette personne
il suit dans cette relation pour le long
terme peu importe qu'elle soit ou non de
la famille royale
ce n'est pas une relation qui se brisent
facilement
c'est pour toujours
c'est déjà la fin de ce jour de mariage
historique il annonce cependant un
avenir prometteur pour cette nouvelle
génération de la famille royale qui est
déterminé à laisser un héritage au
profond retentissement pour le royaume
uni et le reste du monde
[Musique]
m